Speaker 1: All right, let's jump right in
today.
Many topics related to the pandemic that we'll
be talking about.
We'll be talking about an anti vaccine hearing.
We will be talking about lab leak.
But first, let's just kind of reset where
we are.
Coronavirus cases in the United States are
now down more than 94 percent.
We are now at the point where we are asking,
with so many people refusing to get vaccinated,
how much lower a case is going to go because
this thing is going to keep floating around.
Are we getting to about as low a point in
daily cases as we're going to get any time
soon because the virus is going to keep floating
around among unvaccinated populations?
I think the answer is not quite yet.
I think we'll still see a decline, but we'll
know within two to three weeks.
But we are down more than 94 percent from
the case peak in roughly mid-January.
Now, in terms of U.S. coronavirus deaths,
we are now down more than 88 percent in daily
deaths.
Still 400 people a day are dying in the United
States of coronavirus.
It's still a horrible number.
But when we talk about getting back to baseline
risk, I believe it's around 300 people a day
over a year that during the average flu season
die in the United States.
So we're getting very close to that baseline
level of risk that we see equivalent to the
flu.
Four hundred is still high, but it is the
lowest it's been during the the entire pandemic.
You've got to go back to March of 2020 to
find death numbers this low in the United
States.
Now, there are many people saying and if you
emailed me, you know, David, is this actually
because of the vaccines or is this just because
of the seasonality?
Because if you look at cases and deaths last
summer, they were just as low and that's not
at all true.
So the first question is, are the premises
right?
And they are not.
We are now at 14000 cases per day and declining.
The lowest point last summer was 22000 cases
per day.
And they went all the way up to 70000 cases
So it's not even close.
It's not true that cases were this low last
summer.
Now, looking globally, cases are now down
about 50 percent.
Last week, we were down 40 percent from the
global peak.
Now we're down 50 percent from the global
peak.
Remember that the global peak was about 830000
cases per day, an insane number.
So this is already major progress, although
there's still a long way to go in.
Many parts of the world are completely or
almost completely unvaccinated.
And then globally deaths, which, as we now
know, lag cases by several weeks.
Global deaths are down about 34 percent from
their peak.
We still have nearly 10000 people a day dying
of covid globally.
Much of that is the unvaccinated population,
but we are down from more than fourteen thousand
deaths a day.
So everything's moving in the right direction.
Never as quickly as we would like.
But fortunately, vaccinations in the United
States are starting to tick back up again
after months long decline.
So we started seeing this in mid-April.
Daily vaccinations peaked at roughly three
point three million a day.
That was a very good number.
We were hoping to get the three point five
or even four million a day.
But then vaccination started to decline and
decline and decline all the way down to under
one million vaccinations per day.
Over the last week we were down.
Last week, we had a one week average of 930
vaccinations per day in a country of three
hundred and thirty one million people.
It's terrible.
It's pathetic.
It's horrifying.
And we'll talk about the anti back stuff in
a bit.
We are now starting to see a slight uptick
once again, back up to about one point one
million vaccine doses per day.
So there will hopefully now be the more reluctant
people who will start to realize maybe my
school is going to require the vaccine, maybe
my employer is going to require the vaccine.
Maybe the vaccine will be required to go on
a trip to the country that I want to go and
visit.
Maybe you need a vaccine to sit in the vaccinated
full capacity section of your local sports
stadium and maybe that will encourage people
to go and get themselves vaccinated.
Whatever the case, one million vaccine doses
a day just isn't good when we still have so
many tens of millions upon tens of millions
of people who could go and get a vaccine.
These are widely available.
There are countries desperate to get vaccines.
We have so many.
And yet one fifth of the population by last
count just isn't interested.
Now, one thing that does seem like it will
convince people maybe will be full FDA approval
of the vaccines, the the unvaccinated population,
one third of that.
Population says, I will be going to get a
vaccine once the FDA fully approves the vaccines,
remember right now they're approved under
an emergency use authorization, not full approval.
So I would love to believe that as soon as
that approval comes one third of the vaccine,
hesitant folks will go and get vaccinated.
I can't say I'm convinced.
I think it's something that many of them are
saying right now.
And then once that full approval comes down,
they're going to come up with something else.
Now, I also just disagree with the premise
of saying I'm going to wait for the full approval
before going and getting vaccinated, catching
covid.
In the meantime, while you wait for that full
approval is likely statistically to be way
worse than the side effects you might have
from the vaccine before it's fully approved.
And remember, one at once, it's fully approved
and it will be the side effects aren't going
to change.
The efficacy is not going to change.
But with the approval coming, it would be
great to take any of that antibiotics group
vaccine hesitant group off the table and get
them vaccinated if they're if they're genuinely
waiting for full approval and they're really
going to go and get vaccinated at that time.
Great.
I look forward to them doing that.